wonderful thanks a lot it's great to
follow up such an awesome talk
um today i'm going to be talking about
recent work
that i've done with my collaborators on
quantum machine learning
so the basic idea that uh that
uh that we're proposing here is
proposing looking at a very particular
type
of uh of quantum learning in particular
we're looking at generative learning
where we're aiming to not just be able
to discriminate between quantum states
but we'd like to build be able to build
a model
that can actually replicate these and we
the key thing is with these results is
that
we find that we can actually train uh
quantum models for generative tasks
using these objective functions
efficiently
in many cases um and also avoid all
known baron plateau results
which is uh something that's actually
pretty cool because um
well yeah that's a major problem but
before
i begin jumping into more details about
this i really kind of just want to talk
a little bit about like kindergarten
level stuff
before we can kind of get into you know
the rest of it so
we've all seen machine learning at this
point but just for those of you who
haven't
looked at it in too much detail really
what we kind of want to do is we really
want to be able to
uh machine learning is a set of
techniques that we end up using
to be able to build models for data that
we experience in nature so for example
if we wanted to build a cat detector
the way that these models are are built
is rather than coming up with a
deterministic way to say
you know what is a cat or what isn't a
cat for example
we would feed in a bunch of images in
this case of something that's very
clearly a cat and very clearly not a cat
we feed those images into the model and
then we would train it with respect to
an objective function
and this training basically ends up
boiling down to a gradient descent
process you've got some figure of merit
which might be
how accurate for example it gets the
right label assigned with the right
class of image
and then what we want to do is tweak the
parameters of the model in order to
maximize that probability
so this is one of the reasons why i feel
kind of grateful to be talking right
after tong
tong yang because these ideas his ideas
kind of flow very naturally
into the sorts of problems that i'm
going to be talking about here
and so one of the big areas uh or big
successes that we've had in machine
learning
is this idea of deep learning and the
idea of deep learning really
is that what we want to do is we want to
try to build a hierarchical model
of uh of the data that we're generating
so for example
if we wanted to build a cat classifier
like we were talking about before
the idea behind these types of models is
that what you would do
is you would begin by feeding a
raw image
in on this side and this is stored in
these
neurons over here and neurons for our
for our for our case we can just
envision as being individual bits
so like each pixel in a black and white
image we could envision being
represented as a bit saying whether that
pixels on
or off all of those are fed in and the
network rather than making a decision
about whether it's a cat or not
based on the raw pixels what it does is
it starts generating
higher level features at different
layers of abstraction
and these neurons that we're using
in this region these are called often
called
hidden layers or hidden units
okay the reason why is because at the
end of the day
to figure out the output class that
we're providing for the image
we actually only care about these two
neurons at the very end all the rest of
this
stuff in between which generates high
level features
they're just used in order to make this
ultimate decision
that we have in the end and are
fundamentally discarded
so the basic idea is that what we do is
oh i should just
erase this text i forgot about the
animation
so basically what we we do in this
process
is we train it with gradient descent but
we also
ignore all of this stuff in between okay
and this is something that actually is
very important for reasons i'll get to
in a moment
but one of the the things that i i
uh okay i guess i skipped a step here
if we want to talk about quantum uh
computers and uh doing quantum versions
of this
rather than having you know a uh cat
image being put on
this side what we would have is we'd
have kind of like a cat state
now being put on the inside then what we
would have
is we would have a whole bunch of extra
qubits
that we're being that where we use in
order to be able to genera
generalize or find you know a train an
effective
optimal measurement in order to be able
to classify
the quantum states that are coming in
over here so the way that we can picture
this
is that what we do is we have a bunch of
uh we've got a quantum state that's of
the form um
psi visible coming in
and we've got an additional uh register
off to the side
which is a hidden subsystem and a hidden
subsystem
is all this extra memory that we're
using in our particular model
then what we have is the standard
approach that we would use for this is
we would want to build
a unitary model on this that ends up
mapping these quantum states in such a
way
so that the trace over the hidden
of the unitary of theta
acting on the initial state psi v
answer psi h over here
ends up giving us a final state that we
can measure and glean some useful
information from
so this is the this is the the kind of
the standard model
for quantum machine learning that we
typically use these days
now lately this model has been somewhat
upended
because of insights that actually these
types of models
can act can actually in many cases be
next to useless
and in fact in some cases having quantum
effects
in these systems can actually make the
models weaker than
classical models so the first of these
these realizations uh was given by
jared mclean and uh and company and the
basic realization
was that if we consider our quantum
models as being like a unitary
that uh that we're applying to the
quantum system if we choose these
unitaries
arbitrarily and let's imagine that each
of the unitaries was chosen
in by arbitrarily i mean a uniformly
according to the har measure
technically actually for you know for
the t design nerds in the crowd we only
need a tier design condition
but um we imagine it's chosen according
to the heart measure
what we can then show actually is that
the
variance of the derivative of our
objective functions
in in this case actually ends up being
strongly concentrated near zero
and so what that ends up meaning is that
with extremely high probability
if we take a random model and just
choose our parameters arbitrarily
and that unit the resulting unitary is
typical of a har
random unitary then the variance that we
end up getting for
our gradient is next to zero so that
means
basically we run into these situations
like what tong yang was just talking
about
everywhere basically becomes a saddle
point
and the gradient isn't just small it's
actually exponentially small
for all but an exponentially small
fraction of the configurations that we
could consider
and so this is this is a really really
uh
scary result and it says that if we want
to
take advantage of quantum machine
learning in these cases we really sort
of
we can't begin with a naive model we
have to have
a non atypical unitary that we're
putting in something that's very
different from these
random unitaries the next result that
ended up coming up that my co-authors
and i
uh showed that was that was also very
scary
is that you get you can run into a
problem that
we call entanglement induced baron
plateaus and this is an example
here of what people would call in the
community a quantum neural network
so each of these g's you can view as a
parameterizable gate
and this would be a sequence of a
parameterizable gates and imagine what
we've got is we've got
four visible qubits in this and four
hidden uh qubits in it
so what we would do in this particular
case is that we would like to train a
training objective function
and um by measuring the expectation
value
of this qubit at the top that's
basically going to be our exp
our objective function we'd like to get
this uh measurement result to be one in
all the one cases and zero in all of the
zero
classification problem so
if we end up having a complicated
network of parameterizable gates
then what typically what will end up
happening is that these
subsystems will end up becoming nearly
maximally entangled
then if you end up having a maximally
entangled state like zero
zero plus 1 1 right and you decide that
you want to do a partial trace
over one of those two qubits you of
course
end up with a maximally mixed state on
the other the
other subspace the exact same thing ends
up happening with
quantum neural networks if we have a ton
of entanglement
that's generated between this hidden
subsystem
and the visible subsystem that we're
outputting in the end
then actually the resulting quantum
state ends up becoming nearly maximally
mixed
and in that case you can actually end up
showing that not only
is the objective function measurement
that you get in the end
no better than what you would get from
just sampling from the maximally mixed
state with high probability
if you have this degree of entanglement
but also
the um the derivatives that you end up
getting for these types of models
are also going to be with high
probability exponentially small
meaning that you cannot escape from this
these situations
so what this ends up saying is that if
we want to build
analogs of quantum d deep networks we
have to worry
about the entanglement uh between these
two and make sure
that we're using entanglement in ways
that are profitable for our model
and not in ways that are directly
harmful like this
now this is this is somewhat of a new
insight for the quantum machine learning
community
but interestingly enough this is a very
very old
insight for the thermalization community
for people who take
take a look at the foundations of
thermodynamics for closed quantum
systems this is exactly
the same mechanism that explains how the
how the um sort of canonical uh
just canonical as well as micro
canonical probability distributions
end up emerging for closed quantum
systems so
all of this this fact that entanglement
between a system
like these visible units and the bath
down here
is uh ends up leading to something that
looks like thermalization
is an old idea but it's newly being
applied to quantum machine learning
and it really suggests that there
actually you know are some deep
connections
between these two fields that are just
beginning to be explored
so this is a major problem and so we've
got to make sure that we don't run into
these barren plateaus when training a
network like this
from just the hilbert's base dimension
being large like mclean it all talked
about to begin with
but we also if we have these hidden
subsystems
we have to make sure we don't get this
pernicious entanglement
building up between the part of the
state we care about and the part of the
state that we're just
using as a like scratch pad memory to
design our models
and so these two constraints make it
actually very difficult for us in
practice
to be able to say with confidence that
we can train uh models
so the question is well how do we do it
in
in part the the solution that that uh
that my co-authors and i are proposing
is to actually take a look at a slightly
different problem
instead what we'd like to do is uh
rather than discrimination
we'd like to take a look at the problem
of generation and so the idea of
generation is actually very similar to
building an approximate cloner imagine
you've got a box
right and with this box what we'd like
to do is we'd like
a this box is a is a unitary circuit
and it's parameterized by some
parameters theta
what we'd like to be able to do is give
it a feed in an algorithm
a number of copies of particular states
that we'd like it to generate
and then we'd like to learn the
parameters that will end up leading
to the box outputting states that
minimize the distance between the output
quantum state any input states that it
was trained with
so that's the whole idea behind behind
generative training
and the simplest version is really just
like an approximate cloner
the next simplest version which i'm not
going to spend too much time talking
about
um would be one that conditionally
generates the state and this is
something more like what you would see
with auto encoders or other uh models
that
basically attempt to try to create an
identity map
between the inputs and the outputs but
uh
nonetheless the this former problem
can be seen as a subroutine for the
later problem
and i should mention um the a number
of different approaches in classical
machine learning end up taking this
uh for example boltzmann machines are
were an early very popular approach for
dealing with this
uh for doing generative learning and um
auto encoders also are used much more
frequently these days
for generative tasks but there's been a
lot more popularity that's
come about because of generative
adversarial networks which
although they're a little bit different
than uh than a purely generated model
they strongly end up employing um
generative models
as a subroutine inside of uh inside of
the game that they end up playing
between approver and a verifier
in order to classify data but to give
you an
example of this this is a data set that
i've
shown for far too many years that came
out from some early boltzmann machine
work from
selekutenov and hinton and the basic
idea behind this is that what they did
is they trained a
neural network with a bunch of images
on the left and then once the neural
network was trained
then it was capable of generating uh
particular
examples of images that look eerily
close to the original images that it
is trained with and our task here is
we'd like to be able to do the exact
same thing not for images
but for quantum states
so before we begin in you know whenever
you're approaching any problem in
quantum machine learning i really think
that you know
the right thing to ask yourself is
what's the right distance measure
that you want to take a look at now many
early works have taken a look
at the inner product between two
between the input
density or the input states and the
output states
uh as their figure of merit for how well
the network is working and it's it's a
nice metric in the sense that it's easy
to compute
using the swap test however it suffers
from all the known baron plateau results
that that i mentioned earlier so that
means that unless you've got some
intuition before you start
the gradients that you end up getting
for trying to optimize
this objective function uh can be
exponentially small
um however there's other more
information theoretic based
uh metrics that can be used and the most
uh the one that i i personally like the
best
for talking about how similar to quantum
states are is of course the quantum
relative entropy
and the quantum relative entropy
basically what it does is it measures
the number of bits that you need to
encode one quantum state
using the the other with the optimal
encoder and it can also be used in order
to be able to bound the number of
samples that you need to optimally
distinguish between two quantum states
it's very nice because it's got a good
motivation but
there's one two important reasons why
uh or actually probably one really
important reason why it
isn't used all that frequently it's
because of the fact that
this object contains uh uh matrix
logarithms
and if we want to train this then we're
going to have to differentiate
matrix logarithms and that's that's a
major pain
so okay well why is this uh
such a pain well just to give you an
idea you might think oh well
you know if we take a look at the um
uh derivative of uh of the relative
entropy assuming that sigma is a
parameterized quantum state
and rho is just a constant then we only
the only term that's non-constant in the
previous expression i gave is the cross
entropy the trace of the density
operator against the
logarithm of the parameterized one and
you might be tempted to think hey well i
know how to differentiate
logs right the derivative of the log is
just
well derivative of sigma divided by
sigma but unfortunately that rule
only ends up work if the chain rule
works
and one of the assumptions made in the
derivation of the chain rule
is that the derivative ends up commuting
with the function
and that doesn't occur here in fact the
cleanest expression that i know
for the derivative of a matrix logarithm
is this integral expression
and so if we wanted to implement this on
a quantum computer
we'd have to build this guy over here
and we can do we can do that at great
cost using a
linear combination of unitary's ideas
but it's
a real serious pain to do this on a
near-term quantum computer
so the question is can we do something
kind of a little bit easier
and the thing that we we settled on was
looking instead
at um uh instead of this at the maximal
rainy divergence
and the maximal rainy divergence
basically is uh it kind of generalizes
and upper bounds
the quantum relative entropy and one of
the the nice things about it is it's
positive
it's zero if and only if the two state
the two states that you're considering
are the same
and um on top of that it upper bounds
the regular rainy divergences which
um for alpha greater than uh one
are upper bounds on the quantum relative
entropy
so by training this objective function
for any alpha greater than one
what you can you can do is you can also
guarantee that minimizing it to zero
will also minimize the quantum relative
entropy to zero so
that that is a fantastic the other thing
that's really
cool about this is that for the alpha
equals two case
it has a very simple expression it's
just the logarithm of the trace of rho
squared sigma inverse
and note that in this case over here
it's the logarithm of a of a scalar
not a matrix now so because it's a it's
this is an ordinary matrix
or a logarithm not a matrix logarithm we
can now differentiate this objective
function
so the one thing that i wanted to
mention is a little bit of an annoying
point
is that unfortunately the order that you
end up taking
the two terms for rainy divergences as
well as quantum relative entropy
slightly changes the result so we have
to
decide on one of two possible choices do
we take our parameterized model
that's generating the states to be the
first argument or do we take it to be
the second argument
um it turns out that in practice the
second one is much more convenient
or we end up taking the um the
parameterized uh
state to be the first argument the
reason why is that the derivative
ends up forming a uh having a very
simple form
in this particular case so that's
basically
um what we we end up doing so
the basic idea that uh i wanted to
mention
here is that in order to make more
progress and be a little bit more
concrete about this
uh we need to come up with a functional
form for what
sigma is in order to be able to
explicitly write down what the
derivatives
of the of our model are and so we're
going to take the convention
that is used almost ubiquitously
throughout you know the qaoa community
quantum optimization um
as well as quantum chemistry and end up
assuming that our
initial state that we have is just going
to be a product of matrix exponentials
multiplied by some initial fiducial
state that will choose arbitrarily to be
zero
all the hj's that we choose in this
model need to be efficiently simulatable
so in particular choosing them to be one
sparse is an appropriate choice but in
most cases people choose them even more
particularly
to be poly operators then the other
thing that i wanted to mention is that
you know there's going to be in
principle
both hidden and visible uh qubits in
this model
and what we're going um uh what we want
is we want our resultant model for the
state
to be the partial trace over all of
these hidden units
at the top which you were just using to
generate correlations
or actually impurity uh in the uh
in the resultant state so one of the
things that i wanted to mention is okay
well what about
um what about uh entanglement induced
barren plateaus
does our resolve immediately fall apart
for the exact same reasons i mentioned
before
well technically not actually or at
least it doesn't trivially follow
the reason why is that that result was
talking about
the concentration of an expectation
value
of a objective function like uh o
objective where that's just some
matrix uh uh traced against rho
but here we've got um our state
our objective function in effect being a
non-linear function
of theta so that means that basically
because the previous case ended up
assuming that we have um
it being linear and now we've got a
non-linear case
a lot of the stuff that uh that we used
before
doesn't work whatsoever and in fact
we're not able to
just directly turn the crank and show
that this ends up leading to
exponentially small gradients so that's
that's one of the things that's really
kind of neat
we can we can end up going through um
the this expression for sigma
and it's the one of the things that's
very nice about it is that
um once we've chosen sigma to be a
product of operator exponentials against
this fiducial state
then we can just end up using the
product rule now to differentiate each
of these individual operator
exponentials
and going through we end up getting the
following result
which we can then simplify down to this
expression for the gradient
which essentially ends up boiling down
to an
anti-commutator of partial traces of the
commutator
of the hamiltonian that we're we're
interested in time evolved
um with economy uh with a commutator
with sigma
so that's the the the expression for the
gradient
and uh now everything else that i'm
going to be talking about in the next
little while
is just arguing how we can evaluate
the gradient expression okay
um so the first thing that i wanted to
mention is okay well what about this row
inverse right
row here in our context is the training
data the state that we'd like to mimic
um so even if we're given the the state
rho
in some sense how do we end up finding
row inverse well
we can actually always do that thanks to
some work that's
been developed over the years from the
linear combinations of unitary's
community
that shows a polynomial approximation is
possible
to the inverse function for this that
depends on in this case the condition
number of the density operator
so provided that the density operator is
well conditioned
then we can end up using these
techniques in order to be able to
closely approximate the density matrix
but of course if it's ill-conditioned
then this uh this doesn't directly uh
apply
then the next thing that i want to
mention is that
once we figured out a way of doing row
inverse such as using this particular
trick
um we need to worry about computing
expectation values of traces
of the these hamiltonians multiplied by
unitaries multiplied by other density
matrices
so how do we compute these traces that
we have
a present well the way that we do this
by using this
circuit that we call the swap of art
test the reason why we end up calling
that is because
what we want to do with it is we want to
be able to do something it's kind of
like a swap test
and kind of like the hadamard test we'd
like to be able to compute the trace of
products of unitaries
as well as density operators and this
particular circuit which is
literally a hybrid of the swap test and
the hadamard test actually ends up doing
precisely that
so we can run this circuit and use that
in order to compute those
products of expectation values of
density operators and unitaries
when we go through and do this uh using
linear combination of unitary's
techniques
uh we can end up seeing that the number
of queries that we need
to the um to an oracle that provides
each of the exponentials of the density
are not the density operators of the
hamiltonian terms
and also a block encoding of the inverse
of rho
we specified it in terms of the block
encoding of the inverse of row because
we didn't want to have to
go through all the details of
specifically the method used in order to
generate the inverse
because in some cases it's a lot easier
than in others
um but under that assumption the total
number of gates and queries that we we
end up needing to these oracles
in order to be able to um compute the
gradient
ends up scaling like this so this ends
up saying at least it's a query
efficient
under these particular uh assumptions
and in the
under the assumption that the condition
number of row is polynomial
uh we can also white box the block
encoding
of row inverse so
that's fantastic we can efficiently
compute the gradients under some
circumstances
uh of this uh of this objective function
well the next point that's actually very
interesting is that once we have the
objective function
we can go through this exact same har
expectation values
that we went through with the standard
objective function and the interesting
thing of course is that because the
objective function
right has this bit in the denominator
that's absent from the traditional of uh
expressions
what ends up happening is that the lower
bound
that we end up getting on on the
gradients from this
actually it ends up getting normalized
by the
fourth power of the density of norm of
the density matrix
and so what this means is that if this
density matrix that's generated by our
model
is nearly maximally mixed then actually
the
lower bound on the gradients that we end
up getting from the heart expectation
ends up actually not necessarily
yielding something as exponentially
small
so these generative functions unlike um
the standard functions which are just
you know the expectation value of
a matrix
are not necessarily exponentially small
and so we can
in certain circumstances escape from
these barren plateau problems by a
generatively training
so this is something that you know is i
think is a very neat about uh about this
i uh
about looking at generative approaches
but as a particular example
let's talk about uh learning thermal
states
so thermal states are a nice example for
us to talk about the reason why
is that if you recall our objective
function
or gradient over here um ended up having
a row inverse coming in
and so you know ordinarily we would need
a complicated method for computing what
the inverse of a density operator is
but let's consider the case of learning
a um
thermal state if we know what the
hamiltonian is but we don't necessarily
know what the thermal state is
well then we can always express the
inverse of the thermal state
as uh e to the is e to the h times trace
of uh
e to the minus h and so by plugging that
into our expression for the gradients we
actually find this relatively nice
expression
for the gradient of the
maximal rainy divergence between the
thermal state and
the state generated by our model
and so we can run through this and
either use
important sampling on a near-term
computer a quantum computer in order to
be able to assess this
or for more long-term applications we
can use linear combinations of unitaries
to get the best asymptotics
but in any case if we run through all of
this and end up
looking at the asymptotics of
we end up finding that the number of
queries that we
end up needing to um a prepare and
select
oracle for the the hamiltonian as well
as the unitaries used to describe
sigma we end up finding that the number
of queries needed in order to compute
the derivative
of the rainy divergence is this quantity
and it's important to note that if we're
looking at a high temperature state is
in a state where this
one norm over here is a small quantity
then actually this can be computed
efficiently of course
we don't expect in general that this
could be computed efficiently because
the ability to be able to prepare and
sample
from a low temperature thermal state
would allow you to solve np-hard
problems and so if we could if we could
train
a model like this uh efficiently then in
that in
those cases we'd be able to show that np
is contained in bqp
which uh nobody really in their right
mind believes so
um that uh that's why although it's only
restricted to the high temperature case
um it's uh a these
this restriction is reasonable so to
give a bit of an idea uh now that we've
got this
the question is how well does this work
in practice and
from my perspective actually this works
far better than
any model that i've played with in the
past so previously
um all the work that i had looked at
really had kind of mixed results for
increasing
the number of hidden units that we were
using in order to try to describe
a quantum state here what we ended up
finding
for a case of trying to learn a cir
quantum circuit a unitary circuit for
generating
a purely random um three qubit density
up our three qubit thermal states
we ended up finding that basically as a
function of the number of training
epochs that we
ended up uh doing that the loss function
actually was
shrinking exponentially if we gave it
enough hidden units
and uh the loss function uh specifically
the
uh rainy divergence ended up becoming
actually exponentially small in
these cases and so what that ended up
meaning is that basically we had nearly
perfect models
that we were able to learn for these
density matrices
um using just ordinary unitary circuits
and furthermore um the um
fidelities also we similarly increased
and it's important to look at the
fidelities as well as this
metric because of the fact that we're
kind of like training
for this test metric uh
this test loss function on the left and
the fidelity isn't something that we're
trying to train for but you see also
that as we ended up increasing a number
of hidden units rather than hitting an
entanglement induced barren plateau like
you might have expected
our model becomes nearly perfect and so
this actually ends up showing
kind of the power that these models can
end up having
for learning generative uh um
generatively learning
particular quantum states so
to conclude we've given a really a new
method
for uh that can efficiently train uh
quantum
at least under some circumstances of
using rainy divergences and this has
some very nice results because
um all known baron plateau results don't
apply
and this lower bound that we ended up
giving on
the expected uh gradient squared
ends up giving a result that is not
necessarily exponentially small
and that's in contrast to uh ordinary
approaches to training
which normally lead to unconditionally
exponentially small results
um and furthermore you know all the
numerical results that we've done
show that it this this technique learns
extremely well
and uh it ends up saying that you know
for
applications uh in quantum machine
learning and as well as simulation
that require density operate uh
operators
this approach can actually be a nice way
of compiling
um more efficient methods for generating
approximate gibbs states than
than existing approaches might provide
um
but there's more work that kind of you
know uh needs to be done as a result of
this
the first is well i mentioned that you
know this is a generative
approach and it doesn't have the
drawbacks necessarily that
a straightforward discriminative
training would have ie doesn't run into
the baron plateau results
uh at least in a trivial way
one of the applications that potentially
ends up coming up is pre-training then
these results
so the idea behind generative
pre-training would be
what you would do is you'd start with a
training set
and then you would just train your model
in order to be able to approximate that
training set to begin with
that'll put you in the vicinity of a
highly atypical uh
a region in um kind of the the
uh of hilbert's base sort of and then
because you're not in a typical region
the typicality arguments
that we end up getting you needing for
the baron plateau resolve don't apply
and so this could be a way in order to
be able to escape from the initial bad
gradients
that you have at the beginning of many
quantum machine learning algorithms
the other aspect is that having a new
and improved approaches to uh doing
generative training
can actually be used in generative
adversarial and networks and
particularly in quantum approaches to
this
so an interesting idea would be to see
how well the family ends up coupling
uh with those ideas and potentially uh
coming up with new models
that are vastly superior that anything
that we have at the moment
thank you very much
nathan uh thank you very much for the
talk um we have
one question already from bill he asked
how does this approach work when roe is
a pure state
inverse with the pseudo-inverse workers
everything breakdown because of this
number so okay
yeah this is that's an extremely good
point so if you're training with a pure
state
then um then things break down
immediately
under some circumstances uh switching
for to the pseudo inverse as you
suggested is exactly what you want to do
uh in other cases what you want to do is
you want to say okay well maybe actually
i don't i'm
willing to not generate a perfect model
of the initial state
if you introduce a small amount of noise
to begin with then
you'll have you'll have potentially
worse condition numbers coming in
but at least everything will be well
defined and so those are the two
approaches either you inject artificial
noise
into it or you use a pseudo inverse
so i guess one question i have is um
with these models right so in the
beginning since it's approximately
cloning
um how well does this have to learn the
basis for which a quantum state is in
the pure state
perhaps
i'm sorry i couldn't quite hear you uh
james
i said um in the beginning he said this
is approximately cloning
i'm wondering how how does this help
just learning the basis of a quantum
state
okay so basically i i guess the first
thing that i want to be very clear about
is that all that we're discussing uh in
this paper is just the complexity of the
gradient calculation step
we actually make no promises about how
how good of a model
uh following the gradients will actually
end up leading to
so in principle it could be in order to
shed some information
on the uh the rep or the kind of like
meaning of a state
but a lot of this ends up depending on
the quality of the results the gradient
takes you to
which also kind of leads into tong
yang's results
any other questions
[Music]
i think there are more questions um
would this approach work with generative
models using subspaces
um so generative models
um i'm much i'm not sure what that means
i didn't write it it's anonymous so i
don't know who ordered it
um potentially i mean i'd be happy to
talk about that offline but i i really i
really don't know
um what the subspace methods are
uh let's take maintenance